guys in the what what's this movie
called action point action point so
action point stars Johnny Knoxville and
bring some of that jackass danger flavor
and bodily harm to the storytelling
element it starts out Johnny Knoxville
is old and he's talking to his grand kid
about that time he owned an amusement
park so then the movie bounces back to
showing when he was young and he owned
this amusement park which is pretty much
a lawsuit a lot of tetanus shots waiting
to happen there's a lot of danger there
were no rules people are flipping over
things crashing into shed basic jackass
stuff but the kids loved it and this
other amusement park down the road which
you never actually see opens up and so
it's essentially the classic story of
the little guy trying to fight the man
and the guys like we'll just sell your
land you won't have to deal with me as
was Johnny Knoxville being like no we're
gonna make things more dangerous and
more fun while dangerous anyway movies
not that fun I mean when you hear the
premise you're like that sounds awesome
the jackass way of harm coming to an
amusement park and if they pulled it off
it would have been awesome as it stands
the movies just it's really boring
yes it's quite shitty I feel bad for
that cuz I feel like it was a johnny
Knoxville passion project of some sort I
don't know how invested he was with the
movie but I imagine there was some sort
of conversation that came about where he
and a couple other people were like oh
it'd be so great to have this in a movie
be so great to have this stunt in a
movie be so great for me to fly into a
barn and crash through it right now we
need to build a movie around it alright
there you go but whatever happens we
need those little stunts in there even
if it compromises the movie as a whole
which it will because it does I mean if
they'd pulled off the vibe of UHF meets
Ernest goes to camp with a lot more pain
women pretty sweet as it stands just a
shittier version of that I mean this
didn't care about the relationship
between him and his daughter the
daughters mom has a boyfriend and him
getting custody of her is actually it's
talked about in the movie Liz never
really touched on it doesn't matter to
us because we've never met the guy we've
never met her mom not like a liar liar
where there's actual tension between the
dad and the boyfriend it's like they
made up this half-assed story because we
come for the laughs and is the comedy we
do come for the laugh movie never made
me laugh it made me chuckle a couple
times I was just sitting there bored out
of my mind and I was thinking to myself
maybe I'm over it maybe the jackass
stunts just don't make me laugh as much
as they used to but recently enough one
of the Jackass movies came on TV I was
laughing but it could be nostalgia lucky
for
May's group of teenagers well I'd say
teens to 21 year olds behind me perfect
demographic for this they weren't
laughing either that's a live one of
them laughed a couple times at the parts
I chuckled that so what best you're
gonna laugh twice in the movie watch
fail compilation videos on YouTube
they're funny it's pain it looks like it
hurts it'll make you laugh and it'll
make you laugh more than this movie can
possibly make you laugh and it's free
couple of awkward moments of humor also
when they're not relying on people
flipping over things and crashing into
things to make you laugh a lot of
awkward moments that were it was awkward
in his concept to adding this execution
and horrible in this editing so action
point for me it's pretty painful not
painful because you see something on
screen that looks painful you're like
ooh that looks like it hurt that's
painful no painful because it's boring
it didn't make me laugh the charm of
jackass yeah I used charm and jackass in
the same sentence jackass has charm do
something about it she's normal idiots
doing idiotic [ __ ] for our amusement
there's something pure about that movie
does not have any of that it's a hollow
story with hollow characters and most
importantly no laughs I will say it's
impressive to see Johnny Knoxville
actually take those hits though dude
still does he's got to be nearing 50 now
good on him that's why I love Johnny
Knoxville he is a pioneer of pain
however this particular movie I'm gonna
go ahead and say action point is dog
[ __ ] so gonna watch fail compilations
after this isoh action point have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's your favorite jackass ish movie
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to say more
[Music]
you
[Music]